انخفضت اعداد القذائف والصواريخ التي تسقط
على مدينه دانيت وضواحيها الى نصف تقريبا
ذلك ما جعل سكان المنطقه يعودون الى
نشاطهم واعمالهم المعتاده ويرجو المراقبون
والخبراء انخفاض الضربات الاوكرانيه
لمناطق الانفصاليين الى قصف الجيش الروسي
لمستودعات الذخيره الاوكرانيه في مناطق
مختلفه من دانيتسكو هذه السوق قصفت مرات
عديده وقضى فيها بائعون وبائعات عدا عن
الاصابات والدمار الذي حل بالمكان
اما ان تكون القاعده الاوكرانيه ابتعدت
واما ان يكونوا خفضوا القصف لذلك عاد
الناس الى الاسواق ولديهم رغبه بالحياه
والشراء وفي كل مره يعود اصحاب المتاجر
لاعمالهم بعد انخفاض وتيره القصف ويقطعون
مسافات النقل للوصول لمتاجرهم من اجل لقمه
العيش رغم الظروف الصعبه التي تعاني منها
المنطقه
لقد عاد الناس للتسوق والمنطقه اصبحت
مرتضى والحمد لله لا يوجد قصف والمدينه
هادئه
اصبح قليلا واقل بكثير من السابق ونعيش
كما يجب والافضل قادم بالتاكيد والنصر لنا
وتستمر الحياه مع عوده الزبائن للاسواق
وتدور عجله البيع والشراء الى هذه السوق
رغم القصف الذي لم يتوقف مع استمرار
الاعمال العسكريه لقناتي العربيه والحدث
رائد الاغبر دانياسك